all right welcome to the show uh
Governor DeSantis is in Japan he will
join us tonight and uh we'll check in
with him also we're going to ask whether
he plans to run for president we'll talk
about his trip abroad uh whoever gets
nominated by the GOP will likely face
that guy the guy that does not know
today is Monday
he's 82 years old and all we know is he
likes ice cream and he can't speak very
well anyway Joe Biden you're cognitively
struggling Democratic president is now
planning to announce his re-election bid
tomorrow now here's where it gets very
interesting even though almost no one in
America wants him to serve a second term
we're not even sure he can get through
the first term now
that's true Tulsi gabbard will weigh uh
straight uh tonight right here in the
studio with us uh also West Virginia
Democrat Joe manchin will join us
tonight now remember he made a deal with
Chuck Schumer and Joe Biden on the
critical issue to his State it's called
Energy right we need to be energy
independent energy dominant it looks
like they have broken their promise to
him Joe manchin is not happy about it he
is rightly criticizing that criticizing
runaway spending sprees by his own party
he is slamming the president's what he's
calling uh deficiency of leadership and
he's praising house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy and rightly saying that Biden
needs to what is day 81 or two he needs
to sit down with McCarthy and negotiate
a deal on the debt ceiling but is it too
little too late I don't know uh also
tonight Jimmy phela Daga McDowell uh
they will help us Bid Farewell to fake
news enthusiasts
[Applause]
I want you to follow this model on
closely this matters the walls are now
closing in we can report tonight on the
Biden family Syndicate don't don't take
my word for it let's go to Vanity Fair a
left-wing magazine quote Federal
prosecutors now are considering four
charges against Hunter Biden here's NBC
news saying the same same report the
impending charges include at least one
felony count of tax evasion along with a
felony Firearms charge based on several
breaking reports there are indictments
possibly even as early as this week the
weakest father will announce his
re-election plans now according to even
fake news CNN Hunter Biden's lawyers are
meeting with doj officials in the coming
days oddly enough Hunter's criminal case
has been revived from the dead only days
after a career IRS supervisor filed for
official whistleblower protection
accusing the federal government of
shielding hunter from criminal charges
now this claim time is corroborated by
NBC quote two senior law enforcement
sources telling NBC news about growing
frustration inside the FBI because
investigators finish the bulk of their
work on this case about a year ago huh
now they recently reportedly have
sufficient evidence now to charge Hunter
Biden but thanks to the IRS
whistleblower we can now only make the
conclusion that the Attorney General of
the U.S is now apparently standing in
the way and then attempting to cover his
tracks in front of Congress now that
raises a question did the Attorney
General Merrick Garland lie to Congress
thus far the Trump appointed U.S
attorney in this case has been prevented
from bringing charges or fully even
exercising his authority in fact The
Whistleblower purportedly now has hard
evidence that the testimony you're about
to hear from Eric Garland is absolutely
false and that he knew it at the time
take a look does Delaware U.S attorney
lack independent charging authority over
certain criminal allegations against the
president's son outside of the District
of Delaware
um he would have to bring if it's in
another District he would have to bring
the case in another District but as I
said I have promised to ensure that he's
able to carry out his investigation and
that he be able to run it and if he uh
needs to bring in another jurisdiction
he will have full authority to do that
all right attorney general
Merrick Garland is not the only top
federal official Running cover for the
Biden Syndicate now you might remember
the bogus October 2020 letter remember
51 former Intel experts all claiming
that the hunter Biden laptop story had
quote all of the classic earmarks of a
Russian information operation well none
of these Intel experts not one had any
knowledge at all about the laptop by the
way that laptop was in the hands of the
FBI since December 2019. they could have
authenticated that laptop in 48 hours
anyway so the 51 were convinced to sign
a letter anyway and by the way the
person that convinced them is your now
Secretary of State Tony blinken he was
working as a foreign affairs advisor for
the Biden campaign the FBI had it since
December 2019. they likely knew it was
real they also knew it would likely leak
because they knew that Rudy Giuliani
then president Trump attorney had a copy
of it so Lincoln Tony blinken had no
reason to doubt the contents of Hunter's
hard drive but the truth that doesn't
matter to Tony blinkett he is a liar he
is a hack who helped Biden wage what is
a disinformation campaign against you
the American people every one of you
they lied to you they lied because they
wanted to help Joe Biden anyway all in
the lead up in the weeks before the 2020
election let me put it a different way
if blink did blink and commit fraud
against you the American people did he
interfere in our electoral process in
order to push this feeble-minded you
know corrupt boss hiding in his basement
over the Finish Line in other words is
this a legal conspiracy if you defraud
on purpose without any evidence the
American people did he get promised a
job to be Secretary of State in the
process make no mistake Garland and
blinken didn't stick their necks out out
for Hunter Biden this really is not
about Hunter this is important to
understand
when we now peel back what we know about
all of this Hunter's possible crimes and
you take a really hard look at all the
finances what Comer and his committee
and Jordan and his committee are now
discovering we are beginning to see that
the big guy Joe Biden himself is
implicated in very troubling Behavior
thanks to Chairman Comer's ongoing probe
in the house oversight committee we're
now learning more about shell
corporations we had never heard of
before we're learning about llc's with
no clear purpose at all in other words
they have no clear business purpose
we're getting these suspicious activity
reports from Banks and huge payouts from
our geopolitical foes why are the bidens
getting money from China Russia Ukraine
and over a dozen other countries and get
this according to Comer quote China was
probably the most reputable country that
the Biden family was dealing with
that's a statement now first it was only
three Biden members we've suspected
being a part of this last week then they
said it was nine Biden family members
now they're telling us that at least 12
Biden relatives received some of this
money from this quote business or as we
effectually call it on this program a
Syndicate and still Comer can't find any
information about what the multi-million
dollar business actually did now they
certainly weren't paying zero experience
Hunter Biden for his expertise because
he had none so tonight America needs
answers here's the answers we need is
Merrick Garland running interference and
protecting the Biden family did Tony
blinking conspire to lie at the highest
level to the American people in the lead
up to a presidential election to impact
that election and the most important
question here is about Joe Biden himself
is he corrupt and compromised as a U.S
president we know that Eli AI to you the
American people and he said not once did
he ever speak to his son Hunter about
his foreign business dealings how much
money did the Biden family do in
business with China with Russia with
Ukraine and according to James Comer a
dozen a dozen other countries how much
profit did they make how much did Joe
himself get well tonight the walls are
finally closing in on the Biden family
Syndicate hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else